الصحه العالميه تتوقع قفزه في اعداد قتل
الزلزال المدمر مئات العائلات في شمال
سوريا تلتاحف السماء مختصون يقدمون نصائح
في كيفيه التصرف اثناء حدوث الزلازل هذه
الاخبار نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
توقعت منظمه الصحه العالميه قفزه كبيره في
اعداد القتلى نتيجه الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا وحول بنايات عديده الى
حطام بفعل قوته التي وصلت الى 7.9 درجه
مسؤول في المنظمه قال لرويترز انه يتوقع
زياده عدد القتل بشكل كبير في البلدين
خصوصا مع انهيار العديد من البنايات ووجود
اعداد كبيره تحت الانقاض مشيرا الى ان ذلك
سيزداد بشكل ملحوظ في محيط مركز الزلزال
فيما وصل عدد الضحايا الى
1541 قتيلا واكثر من ثمانيه الاف اصابه في
تركيا وحوالي 911 قتيلا في سوريا بمناطق
النظام والمعارضه
وفي سوريا تحديدا افاد صليب الاحمر الدولي
بان فرق لانقاذ في هذا البلد لا تمتلك
المعدات اللازمه لاغاثه المنكوبين مشيرا
الى ان مئات العائلات اصبحت في العراء
نتيجه الزلزال الصليب الاحمر اوضح في بيان
ان العاصفه الثلجيه والوضع الامني يعيقان
مساعده منكوبي الزلزال بسوريا خصوصا في
مناطق الشمال التي تعج بمخيمات النازحين
لافتا الى ان الزلزال دمر عددا من
المستشفيات في هذا البلد فيما طالب المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان الجهات الدوليه
بالتدخل الفوري لانقاذ المصابين والوقوف
على الكارثه الانسانيه في ظل الضعف فرق
الانقاذ السوريه
هذا هو رجحت هيئه المسح الجيولوجيه
الامريكيه بنسبه 34% ان تصل تكلفه الاضرار
الاقتصاديه للزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا اليوم
لاكثر من مليار دولار امريكي موقع ارتمسال
البريطاني والمختص بالتحليلات الاقتصاديه
اوضح ان الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا يعد
واحدا من اكبر الزلازل التي سجلتها
المنطقه على الاطلاق فيما بلغ عدد المباني
المتضرره حتى الان اكثر من 1800 مبنى في
تركيا وحدها كما لحقت الاضرار بما لا يقل
عن عشر مدن رئيسيه بينما شهدت منطقه شمال
سوريا اضرارا كبيره ودمارا مهولا حيث تم
الابلاغ عن نحو تضرر 200 مبنى على الاقل
لكن ماذا نفعل لو تعرضنا لزلزال سؤال شغل
بال الكثيرين على السوشيال ميديا بعد هذا
الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
واجاب عن هذا السؤال مختصون وباحثون
فللوقايه قبل وقوع الهزات يجب تثبيت كل ما
يمكن ان يقع في المنزل مثل الخزانه واشياء
ثقيله اخرى الى جانب تصليح التشققات في
المنزل والاسلاك الكهربائيه اضافه الى
تحديد اماكن امنه في الخارج بعيدا عن
الابنيه واعمده الكهرباء اما اثناء وقوع
الزلزال فينصح الخبراء بالاحتماء تحت
طاوله المتينه او عند عتبه الباب
والابتعاد عن النوافذ والشرفات اضافه الى
قطع مصادر الطاقه اذا امكن وعدم استعمال
المصعد الكهربائي
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرنا الاخير تداول رواد السوشيال
ميديا تغريده مثيره للجدل لباحث توقع قبل
ايام زلزاله تركيا وذكر الدول التي ستتاثر
به الخبير الهولندي والباحث في شؤون
الزلازل فرانك هوجر توقع بالضبط قبل ثلاثه
ايام بدقه في تغريده الله على حسابه على
تويتر قائلا عاجلا ام اجلا سيضرب زلزال
بقوه 7.5 درجه المنطقه المحيطه بجنوب وسط
تركيا والاردن وسوريا ولبنان فيما قال
ناشطون ردا على هذه التغريده ان العديد من
تنبؤات هذا الباحث الهولندي كانت خاطئه
لكن توقعاته حول زلزال سوريا وتركيا كانت
دقيقه بشكل مخيف